avons-nous fait ça d'
accord je suis belle nuit jeunes
dieux
voici pour nos mères on m'a offert
un travail je pensais que toi et Tom viendrais
avec moi tu veux dire bouge bouge d'ici deux
belles femmes comme toi c'est juste que vous
deux êtes de gentils garçons  ce n'est pas vraiment
sain est-ce que
tu as tout ce dont tu as besoin non la
nuit dernière j'ai surpris ma mère sortant de sa
chambre c'est impossible où
étais-tu à lilz en train de lui faire ce que
Ian t'a fait
ça ne peut pas se reproduire
je ne me souviens pas  être si
heureux tout cela est inacceptable ne
comprends pas je l'aime
je suis sûr qu'ils vont s'ennuyer de nous bien assez tôt
tu viens ici nous devons rester
ensemble c'est de ta faute car nous ne sommes pas
seuls ce bordel  ça fait une différence
oh mon dieu essayer de s'entre-tuer
je ne maîtrise pas je ne vois pas pourquoi nous devons
vous